Senator John McCain has been fighting
brain cancer for some time we've known
about it since July of 2017 I believe
and a few days ago we heard that he had
discontinued treatment for the
glioblastoma he has passed away 4:30
p.m. a couple of days ago at age 81
survived not only by his immediate
family but also by his hundred and six
year old mother an outpouring of mostly
support from people on the political
right of course also people on the
political left despite being a
Republican McCain had many friends both
personally and even with some
ideological crossover in the Democratic
Party and through John McCain will we
can talk about his politics but through
John McCain we really saw how not only
does politics create strange bedfellows
but it also sometimes creates unusual
enemies or at least adversaries in some
cases John McCain had been at odds with
Donald Trump for some time Trump
ridiculing McCain's military service
McCain of course a prisoner of war
saying he prefers soldiers who don't get
captain don't get captured or heroes who
don't get captured and John McCain
making it clear according to a CNN
report that he does not want Donald
Trump at his funeral Donald Trump
regardless still tweeting quote my
deepest sympathies and respect go out to
the family of Senator John McCain our
hearts and prayers are with you so on
the one hand there was this very
significant rift rhetorically between
Trump and McCain in the end it's
important to remember that when the
rubber met the road if you look at how
frequently they voted in line with each
other John McCain did vote in line with
Donald Trump's position 83% of the time
now that's arguably low compared to
maybe most Republicans who are in the
high 90s in lockstep with Donald Trump
but it is still someone who for the most
part agreed with Donald Trump on the
substance of the bills if not on the
rhetoric and the tone so what can we
glean from all of this putting aside the
political differences with John McCain
and and I had many differences with John
McCain he did meet a different minimum
of decency and decorum that has been
widely missing from the Republican Party
one notable moment was during the 2008
campaign against Barack Obama when a
clearly ignorant xenophobic woman in the
audience told McCain she thinks Obama is
an Arab and McCain said no he's not we
just disagree about politics I'm gonna
play the clip for you now of course it
would have been nicer for McCain to say
even if he were an Arab that's not an
argument and that would be okay and we'd
still have to figure out who's right on
policy but still this was an interesting
moment John McCain was involved in I
gotta ask you a question
I don't not believin I can't trust Obama
III have read about him and he's not
he's not he's a he's an Arab he is not
no no ma'am no ma'am he's a he's a he's
a decent family man citizen that I just
happened to have disagreements with on
fundamental issues and that's what this
campaign is all about he's not thank you
asked how he wanted to be remembered
McCain said he served his country and
not always right made a lot of mistakes
made a lot of errors but served his
country and I hope we could add said
McCain honorably so was John McCain a
politician I agreed with no he was more
or less a standard neoliberal Warhawk i
I still can't square that decision he
made the totally incompetent Sarah Palin
being brought on as his running mate in
2008 still can't understand that and
like most senators who are part of the
system McCain was responsible for
countless deaths through his support of
American policy and different
interventions in other countries but
what can we say today he did relate in a
way that at least appeared to be much
more genuine and authentic to his
politics into his statements he actually
did seem to have principles that he
applied to his politics I thought they
were often incorrect but they were
principles will Trump be at McCain's
funeral ultimately it seems like the
answer is no and ultimately no one is
going to remember that former President
Obama informed
President George W Bush have both been
asked to speak which will have the
double benefit of Obama number one just
being a really good person to do this
and of enraging Donald Trump but it
tells us so much about the state of
politics in the United States today
where the current president the same
party as a notable senator who dies
isn't asked to participate and the
president from the opposite party is we
will have more for you later in the week
about John McCain but a couple of other
notes related to John McCain first